we want to get more on hope in fact from
our dr. David agus who joins us from Los
Angeles with his reaction to the story
we just heard and also to discuss what
it looks like for someone after
coronavirus how about that what an idea
there is an after dr. David yet egg is
good morning good morning so what does
recovery look like it's a I mean first
of all they're beautiful stories of
people getting better and offering
stories of hope to everybody else the
incubation period for this virus is
about two to nine days and then
classically when they present what's
different about this virus is your virus
load is highest when you present with
symptoms it doesn't go up with time
after you present its highest M which is
probably why you're so infectious and
the average time is about 10 days of
these significant symptoms until you
start to improve so it's a very long
disease course and then going home
you're not perfect yet you've got a long
road to recovery afterwards but you're
home and you're out of danger you always
feel better when you're at home so David
what are doctors learning about the
patients that have recovered what are
they learning from them well we're
learning in several small studies is
that the virus can last longer than we
thought in the blood that doesn't mean
they're contagious but we're seeing
virus out you know 20 30 days and that's
unusual and also you know normally when
you go home from a hospital you can have
a physical therapist rehab and go to the
gym well in today's world you're home
alone so it's a much harder course for
the average patient after corona than
other diseases historically because you
got to do it yourself but you know you
really need that rehab yeah you're not
starting you know though you're better
the next day you have to slowly build up
your oxygen capacity your muscle
capacity because you got knocked down
with a sledgehammer dr. agus on this
theme of hope one possible treatment
we've been hearing about it involves
blood plasma what is that and why do you
like it why do I like it I mean there's
a in 1918 in the Spanish flu we did this
which is taking people who've been
exposed to the virus and gotten better
and we take out their plasma which was
the part of the blood the yellow part of
blood which has antibodies that
the virus and we actually give plasma
from one patient to another patient so a
patient has got better their plasma can
hopefully help somebody who's struggling
against the virus and the FDA has
enabled clinical trials to start at
about 24 centers across the country to
try to do this it's obviously not
scalable it's very hard to do but the
hope is it can work you worked in a bola
and we hope it can work here also all
right dr. David agus doctor thank you
very much